ah hi everybody my floral I'm in the
office Jesus Christ
no shoes allowed but who but [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I can't do it I can't do a video
with a cough drop in my mouth and tell
you're right it's much better than this
is soaking into the carpet right now see
that if no one mentioned did it be fine
alright no one will mention it no one's
gonna mention that note the cough drop
yeah no one mission no one mentioned
anything throughout the video in the
comments in the description nowhere
mention that cough drop on the floor
right there anyway welcome to gang
beasts I've done one other video of this
and we've played a bit for ourselves
just before this but I've never played
it on a couch with my friends here my
only friends the only friends will put
up with me
does anyone forward the game some
couches anymore no that's a desolate
goods daddy that's missing out of the
other gaming community its couch game a
lot of games they're not even coming out
with like local multiplayer anymore
anyway we're off topic let's get into
gang beefs there's two game modes now
there's survival which is the normal a
few new maps added that but there's also
wave mode where we play against NPCs so
we're gonna do survival and then in the
next episode we're gonna do waves so yes
we nice tits sweet awesome rack Oh
epic nips bro right listen
alright ever seen oh my god
don't you come over yeah never let go
why are you going away
I was good that's good what happens if
you go on the buoy okay hold on for dear
life
huh
yeah do it do it no oh hey Mari [ __ ]
Oh
Wow what did you put up a lot mmm
[ __ ] hell ah thank you welcome hey
you know what your guys is far I will it
do ah see you
my god is it my microwave you do wait so
how do you break missing you have to
just sort of hit oh [ __ ] headbutt it
like kick it or punch lunch at her head
butter yeah yeah marki psychopath yeah
yeah I guess like it ah just wanna watch
the world burn
[ __ ] your skis [ __ ] your skis yeah
you're the only one standing on your
skis
just letting it happen
I heard this oh my god
coming around sup [ __ ] boom [ __ ] why
that would just break [ __ ] cuz I jumped
off it's a heart broke that's why ship
Oh God Oh No deidara I'm rooting for BA
please continue well are you ready for
anyone we all suck yeah bad guy pretty
bad yeah what is this
oh yeah ah oh ha ha
hey gather wait wait gobbling yeah like
oh ah ah she begged me to come back get
me up me oh my god oh oh oh [ __ ] oh God
Wow whoa hey hey buddy
now the tables have learned one in the
[ __ ] show okay you win no good thing
oh come hang out this baby right oh come
on I'm coming
oh wait on your way Oh all this gonna
happen oh oh Jesus Christ why do we keep
doing this so much Oh apparently that
happened I don't know that was oh oh oh
geez all right well I think we all
remember this time not to wait for dear
life you piece of [ __ ] god I'm just
gonna get back Oh Oh God go get off ha
ah good idea bud I'm doing good
yeah oh oh he's back ha hey turn oh my
god oh can you bring cookies why they
grab you and not the balloon was trying
to grab the boy but it'll wrap you
little one we all three tired that round
got it shut
ah oh whoops that was supposed to be
more profound whoop oh sweet lord its
anything over oh oh oh my god dad am
you can't hi hi everybody
trying to jump aground I'm coming for
you I'm coming for you oh damn I can't
[ __ ] goddamnit oh oh oh you didn't mark
I'm going over here
oh holy well I got rid of Wade that was
easy
I'm gonna hang out in here paradise ha
that's before what happened ha ha let me
guess these break - I think so not
imagine it Oh God oh how do I get up
there you told well being of German to
the other elevator we can break the
glass ok we're almost there we're almost
there and or the odds I could break the
glass in it I don't know my god hey what
no please
Bob a slip knot I didn't do anything
yeah wait why did I grab you breath no
his karma doesn't like you come on bring
it bring it
No
just [ __ ] mark is a wizard apparently
winter losses sorry okay what as fast as
I can
oh oh this is bad you wanna get off of
the how do you get out of here hahahaha
oh yes yes oh my god [ __ ] I'm not a
[ __ ] come out of here come here [ __ ]
oh my god I'm a coach on you
I was not Dwyer God huh you like you'll
never gonna get me in here you like
having sausage in the corner yeah oh
good bye bye Bilbo
are you gone your run away cuz you're
scared good Wow no oh come on whoa
[ __ ] [ __ ] was that
oh all right so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you Bob and weed
for joining me on this episode of gang
beasts I hope you enjoyed it if you did
let us know we might play more very soon
you never know we're gonna try to get as
many variety of games on this couch
while they're still in LA as we can but
thanks again everybody for watching and
thank you guys for joining me there
links are in the description below check
out their YouTube channels they're
really fun to feature my close friends
so thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye